their mother is missing and feared dead
the family thinks she may have been one
of at least 56 people killed by soldiers
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
the killings happened in the city of
Goma on August the 30th when the
military allegedly fired live ammunition
to break up a demonstration calling for
U.N peacekeepers to leave the country
I knew she had gone to church so when
some neighbors told me she was killed in
a shooting I didn't believe it I went
there I couldn't find her I rushed to
the morgue I was unable to get in there
were so many bodies and it was hard to
identify anyone I went to the prison but
I couldn't find her my husband is still
looking for her
six soldiers including a colonel and a
lieutenant colonel have been charged
with crimes against humanity murder
malicious destruction of property and
inciting soldiers to commit violent Acts
Genie kanyenge went to the court hoping
for some information on her missing son
or at least on where his body may be
we don't know where they took the body
they are telling us they took the bodies
in military trucks and headed towards
the lake in a neighborhood of Goma
[Music]
many people are being treated in
hospital for gunshot wounds the U.N
peacekeeping mission in the DRC which
includes more than 12 000 soldiers has
faced repeated protests in recent months
anger is rising among people who say the
operation has failed to protect them
from attacks by various armed groups in
the mineral-rich region of Eastern DRC
the authorities had banned the most
recent demonstration which was organized
by a religious sect the government has
condemned the military's response and
promised those responsible will be
punished but it's still not known
exactly how many people were killed or
where the at least 32 people still
missing are
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera